well this weekend millions of us watch
the big game
high stakes on the gridiron and
incredible pressure from the players to
the coaches
and especially the referees well since
february is american heart month we're
going to take a closer look at one man's
journey
battling back from a heart attack to
return to the family and the game that
he loves
[Music]
touchdown rusty spindle dedicated three
decades of his life to the game
as an officiant for d1 football and
later the nfl
great part of my life i never looked at
it as work but that work
came to a dead stop when at 35
spindell suffered a heart attack i had
high blood pressure prior to that
a little bit overweight you know not
really taking care of myself like i
should have
and woke up one night feeling really bad
he
passed out and was rushed to the
hospital diagnosed with an overactive
vagus nerve and mitral valve prolapse
it shut all the blood off to my heart
now the amazing thing it didn't do any
damage to my heart it just knocked me
out cold
and came close to dying so close
he remembers floating toward the light
the nurse
then was just sitting there and rubbing
my hand and tried to calm me down
and i got better his young sons and wife
took him home a few days later
and the whole family started a new way
of life i got on a
weight program eating right doing all
the right things and the funny thing is
denisha and i talked you know i've
refereed football for years
i would go through system reference
football i was in great shape and
everything in the off season
you know i i kind of piled it on now
retired from football
spindell sticks to daily exercise and
does his best to manage stress
allowing him to watch his sons grow up
and enjoy
50 years of marriage i had and still
have a good life
so it was important it was more
important for me to be alive
for my family than for me
now rusty has a condition that millions
of people have
mvp some people call it leaky valve so
here's a look at the heart so the mitral
valve is actually one of four valves in
our heart
but it's supposed to act sort of like a
one-way door it controls the blood flow
it's kind of located right about here
now it's supposed to securely open and
then securely close but when you have
mvp it doesn't quite do that the flaps
of the valve don't close evenly
and that actually causes sort of like a
backward flow
of your blood now the thing is a lot of
the times there's very few symptoms if
any symptoms at all and it can get worse
over time and that puts you at higher
risk for a heart attack
two percent of americans have mvp and
they don't even know it